and the local people since they don't  have Jazz Fest they're delivering the  Jazz Fest food while you Jazz Fest in  place and one of the foods that is being  delivered one of the classic Jazz Fest  foods is called crawfish bread oh my god  let me tell you something about this it  is it is a local red berry and inside of  it is two different types of melted  cheese and crawfish it simultaneously  gives you your fat and bread to soak up  alcohol perfect festival food it's great  it's like pizza times 10 it sounds like  that poutine we had up there the bread  right it sounds delicious  [Applause]  the jury to the stories that define the  artists claim who are they what are they  what will you see the what which bands  this year that matter David brats diner  and Barre chords